taken your clothes off uh quite a bit in
movies yeah i mean not because i'm proud
of anything
um i mean there are actors that have
taken their clothes off in movies
michael fossbender that you know
you know there's something people see
what they have yeah um but you've taken
your clothes off in in scenes where it
wasn't even required you're like in a
bank scene you're like naked
well you know i had this thing where
it's like i can't stand it when you see
two lovers in a film and then
the guy gets out of bed and he's got his
boxer shorts on in the morning i don't
really believe that if they haven't got
kids the guy's not sleeping with his
boxer shorts on her like
the dragging the comforter across the
room kind of move or wearing it that
people do when they've been together for
years
you don't find that yeah i'm completely
clothed at all times in my marriage
that always makes sense to me because
i'm always complete you walk around
naked a lot here at the show you're
naked uh well there's also like
you know and i've also
done it in front of other famously
well-hung actors like liam neeson you
know and um
doesn't everybody know
um
that is the well-known rumor about liam
neeson yeah there's a list of actors
and talk show hosts who are on this list
that we don't
no and the point is yeah
the point is enough it's disgusting
absolutely i want off the list i totally
understand i totally understand but i i
got naked in front of liam in a movie
actually and um
for a scene where my character you were
shooting a movie you didn't go to a
movie together okay
hey let's go check out pacific rim
but i was playing a guy who wanted you
knows in kinsey and i was playing a guy
who was maybe bisexual i guess and
they're alone in a hotel room and he
gets out of the shower and i just took a
little extra long toweling off in front
of him
anyway
later on that day
the director bill condon said so i have
an idea for an extra scene that's not in
the script it's a sex scene and just go
back to your trailers and you know get
in your
your little socks or whatever you're
going to wear and come back and we'll
we'll do it and i know that liam and i
both went back to our trailers like you
know
petrified at what the possibilities
might be you know he's irish i'm
midwestern it just wasn't like it wasn't
in my vocabulary waking up i'm totally
fine except that it's liam neeson and i
we just want to know what it's going to
be it's the confusion is bothering us so
we come back to set
and he says
so i'm just thinking you're 69 in each
other and there was like a great sigh of
relief because this is something like we
understood this is something that was
familiar somehow
those kids movies you want to be in
i hear nickelodeon's on the phone i want
to talk to you
they're lining up around them
you're going to 16 on each other
oh boy
i thought this was going to get
embarrassing
it seemed equal it seemed it seemed like
there was not going to be anyone in
charge it was just going to be sort of
sedate and equal you're making it worse
you were his yin to your yang
yeah it was all good